hey thanks your enemy bent over facebook
on what we call a javascript
infrastructure team previously worked on
the mr. ganti when we lived in
California but switched windows to New
York they're talking about a lot of
stuff that we've been able to open
source over the past year and a half or
so and I'm really thrilled about that is
the Parts I contributor some of my best
work I really proud of the offering that
if you want to continue this
conversation afterward I am Benjamin
without the eye on most forms of sokovia
gonna put instagram and facebook so yeah
I am reprising this talk in part two
separate previous thoughts that I hated
Brooklyn j/s with months ago and last
weekend for x so this this type of talk
goes into
more death neither of those two thumbs
so one thing you may notice that a good
mother capitalizing which I might talk
correctly because I didn't know how I
just forgotten like what the rules are
prepositions in your title innovation we
can torrent so look for it seems like
maybe not capitalized in such a long
board of course I meant to Wikipedia but
we do this right try to be this article
about letter case turns out they have a
whole section just about headings
publication titles how you should
capitalize them and it turns out that
there's just a host of conflicting ideas
that I used to this and you can that be
coming straight as I almost did until I
get up and I kept looking thankfully I
have another website that I thought was
really cool table capitalization com
and instead of trying to explain to you
what it's going to do or what the lake
reservations you should have about that
maybe you just copy and paste your title
into this text field and that was almost
too quickly it's done it's capitalized
for you and it cited not capitalized
towards that's what I don't go there you
can see the rules here so this sort of a
trivial example of a general case
planned on going make tonight the
opportunity is technologists to make
certain kinds of problems just disappear
forever so whether it's title
capitalization or automatic memory
management of self-driving cars this is
how history is going to judge our
efforts as people do John computers
according to the number and importance
of problems that we made disappear it
also may be good remembering importance
of new things that we made possible so I
find it it often happens in the course
of engineering that you have a bright
idea but it's not quite complete because
yeah yeah is that you should have been
doing everything some other way all
along and that's that's fine it's nice
to have you no remorse and shame about
the past and productive way that might
help you when you're starting from
scratch in the future but that doesn't
really help you here
working on a large project you can't
just start over and so in order for yet
they're really good and complete I get
not only you have to have this insight
also have to have some clever idea about
how to pretend as if you could go back
in time and everything differently so
I'm going to tell some stories tonight
about how hit this insight and then in
figure out a way of implementing it at
Facebook and their stories so I guess
github is good example of a vast
menagerie of such ideas by the way it's
definitely better ways of doing
something according to some lime juice
case that just never have properly
evangelized because it's a lot of Africa
to explain it so much why they should do
things differently and why your use case
is enough similar today that yeah so
there has to be a way for from where you
are right now with your bright idea
nothing should again and programming
languages like JavaScript Python any
programming language that is
very large step function to some human
version with everyone should start using
are notoriously difficult as items of
technology to fix forward in this way so
if i can ask like the incendiary
question yet to incendiary in this
environment that might be in others it's
been 15 years since Python 3 was first
released and intended to be used why why
aren't losing a thing of those of you
can use my country where you smile at
all how many of the rings by country but
I don't the base rate was yes how many
people just like on every maybe sixty
percent feelings okay yeah so python is
great language python to is one of the
successful programming languages all
time and five on three fixes and things
but the migration is difficult i clean
because they're all these things you
usually just blink you'd like Haley's
but then just a few features that are
semantically different enough actually
ever getting around to that upgrade it's
just too difficult so if I thought
people have this critical to
you can run your code convertibles print
keywords to function calls that's
something that changed and that's okay
that you don't have to do that by hand
what I country has also changed the
semantics of new book this is I'm three
talks on that night go into that that
that turns out to be something where
people Tabler solutions already be very
difficult to adjust all of the code to
accommodate those new assumptions and
that amounts to reason enough for most
people large projects of Jenga not every
switch take on three so more relevant
question perhaps thing is how can
atmosphere six which is the technical
name for the next version of Java
scripts avoid this Python 3d trap so the
crazy idea that we're sort of testing at
Facebook is that maybe you could ease
into the new language by simulating is
most useful features in the current
version of java script which is
definitely both extra five so why would
you want to do this well and gives you
the opportunity to come up with these
intermediate versions
never necessarily exists for anyone else
but on a case-by-case basis you can
decide wishing features of the language
you want to use and even if you never
fully switch to the native
implementation of an exploration of a
language you still end up with a pretty
good fruit base that has a bunch of the
benefits of that new version so that's
what we're doing
okay so if if we're simulating features
of the next version of the language
which is basically while we started out
pretty motley one of them is this new
syntax / what are called arrow functions
so in JavaScript you write a lot of
callback functions so you see that
function keyword with parameter list and
a function body after it all over the
place and arrow functions and active
effort to make that more concise and
also solve some of the problems of
function finding that people up that's
why we thought it would be a good idea
to provide a facebook i should mention
these slides are available online at the
philadelphia github aiello / visible
dish yep damn talk and it's the reason I
mention that is participate we want to
play with these examples they are alive
editable on so you can see as I change
the input it's changing
okay so what does an arrow function well
in this case it's what she passes the
arguments that sort function so you may
know the JavaScript as this court or if
you have an array of numbers and you
call sort without a custom comparison
function the transom all into strings
sorts them in alphabetical order so the
sim big worry for this array would be
110 28 3 which is nonsense and so what
you ought to do if you care is provided
only comparison function to make sure
that the university care Atlas number is
rather than strings so that's what we're
doing here the comparison function takes
two variables scratch one from the other
to get a negative or positive 40 member
that turns up enough to get so we would
expect which is 13 10 so the other nice
feature of error functions as you'll see
is that there is a spy intended games of
time so that captures the value of this
man was in soap something would block
and forget to do or how to do and so you
just don't have to think about
all my name being concise okay so how
you like you know this this is not legal
javascripts index right now input how do
you make it available so we have some
tools that we use a Facebook but I allow
you to parser code into an abstract
syntax tree which is just a tree of
objects where each node corresponds some
piece of syntax like for loop function
or a literal and then you can traverse
that tree and whenever you find
something that you're looking for in
this case look and euro function
expression modify it so right its body
and just in case the body is an
expression instead of like curly brace
delimited playing with a return
statement side of it then we turn it
into blog sina because that's what's
legal in today's JavaScript and then
what we really want instead of error
function expressions that's not legal
yet is my old function expression so the
copy all this stuff from the error
function into a function instruction and
then people buying on that and I guess
the tick of the rest of the presentation
being somewhat they are less stress what
we're doing here is we're we're writing
code
we're building up the structure of some
code this happens to be very verbose way
of doing basically what you do when you
type on the keyboard and write code but
it's but it's very similar these block
statements and function expressions and
call expressions are what you would type
with parenthesis and doubts and
characters the benefits this even though
it's so verbose is that it's completely
on videos it makes it easier to write
algorithms if you transform cotinus will
hear going for the last thing to do is
just replace the original narrow
function expression with the binding
circuit so if you press the code and the
stores and then reprint the code you get
back out me happy with nothing that
isn't illegal in today's dollars so in
what i just showed me it was literally
enough to do at least already have a
build stem for aesthetic resources
creative start using arrow functions in
your code so if you're already using
browsers for instance and building here
your static resources than a short step
away from having disability the pics of
that recast thing that i showed you
it's a tool that's meant to make this
kind of traversal and mortification will
be easier and I cannot both be the name
of the sort of product so it recursively
traverses abstract syntax trees so yes T
sort of makes sense but recasts also a
verb means to give it my log Jabba to
perform by humming it down and reshaping
it for to form fashion range again the
remodel reconstruct or supply like that
theater worked with you can stability
and the interfaces is also pretty
delightfully simple you just require an
ass we parse a string of source code to
do a nasty anything you want vsd doesn't
matter and then you find it back out
magic is that we cast will try to reuse
original source code that wasn't
affected by your modifications to the
syntax tree so two very large at skin if
there's some part that I've filed in
touch or some body of the function that
you might move around actually change
the
the function that code just gets copied
directly so you can use this tool to
generate human readable gifts that are
only change in places that night rather
than printing the whole file in some
completely different style is he
comments idiomatic workspaces of the
altar of the parser hood pins on the
Escrima nursery in rem came up with the
term for this technique is called
non-destructive partial source answering
ok so that was herro functions and your
regular conservation is some today
another new feature of atmosphere six
flexible rest friends sort of a solution
for the awkwardness of the arguments
object if you've dealt with that when
people have touched the argument after
no dance good okay so how's this working
I've seen it before basically one of
your parameters in function can about
that back before and that Granberry an
array contains all of the remaining
arguments that will pass the function so
this is just sort of like a fat mass
with a 10-5 implementation it goes
through the second through however many
arguments that you cast and if it goes
is rare than the previous massive signs
a variable to to the new value
again right
okay so what is this become well
unfortunately at the end of the day we
do have to use the arrogant object so
that's the only way to the unnamed
against to function so this generates
code that slices the argument subject to
get our wheel array excluding and if the
actually games brothers and then may
notice is an error function here as well
for that for years fall back that needs
to become a normal function expression
doesn't actually feet bound in the state
states using this yeah I could just show
you this is actually happening change
the name of that one there hey any
questions about this okay there's only
time for questions
okay so this is even more
straightforward actually we've already
seen we want to find all the functions
that have restaurants we want to build
up that change number expression to read
I prototype that slice a call for the
cumbersome but at least I have to look
at it and then the arguments with a
separate object just like a fire on a
little make a call expression out of
those two things and assign the results
of that call inspection to a variable
declaration that has the same name as
the strengthen and then stick that new
variable declaration at the end of the
function and we need a restaurant
because we've simulated okay so let's
rest around there's another feature
that's they learn to this admittedly
like not the most groundbreaking of new
features but every little thing that
keeps you from you know cutting yourself
on the sharp edges of foods business so
something that is more an actual
especially given the sort of background
in philosophy the many engineers from
the facebook which is that we are
supporting new syntax replying classes
in necklace or six so what we want to do
why it is something that looks like
dollars plus bosses are Python we have a
class that extends base class optionally
constructor and its methods can invoke
superclass overridden versions of
themselves by the methods so what does
it become if we're translating it back
to jobs quickly we can use as well there
needs to be a constructor function
called direct and when I call suburban
surely doing isn't booking that the base
class instructor with the area and then
you gotta set up the whole prototype
chain as you may know these are bent
creek for that and so the instance that
will work this is an old like Lindsay
browser about you need to actually set
the constructor property to be the
construct way that this prototype is
attached to and then methods like get
values become properties of the
prototype and calls to super light super
not get value references to the base
class from this case V Star prototype
that get value and then static methods
are just properties that are attached to
the construction site so that's that's
the goal what's the hook so the the
actual transform game not going to go
through from the states because it's a
good deal more involved a lot of sort of
nasty that's to deal with but the
transform flip that we actually use a
Facebook is open source so if you look
at the top and click on this
the its class visitors classically
everything you ever wanted to talk about
I thought it ought to be done the
project is called jazz transform Jeff
Larson is the primary author of them so
this is a bit of a lie we you might hope
that our our old style of writing
classes looks anything like this extra
five but doesn't our oath glasses
actually looks at their best something
like this you would import this class
module which is for sending stuff and
then this copy properties function which
is sort of like I've got stand and then
you can't be much properties into the
prototype or static properties on to the
constructor and you wanted to do
something like super you would say this
stuff parent which backed by this meta
prototype thing that was like leaves we
populated with methods as implemented in
the base class and I might area motive
and what I'm going to describe is
getting great all of that completely
just making it disappear from the code
base so this goes what you see now
largely it's is nowhere to be found in
facebook live am given the for thousands
on thousands of places that was used
that I guess asus where it's an
explanation
so the original plan their research that
we were to have capsular plant wine so
that whenever you review code the added
properties to a prototype it would yell
at you I'm telling any we're probably
doing something wrong and then there'd
be like media a link in that warning to
some wiki article we have on why you
might be wrong and we were definitely
definitely not like post in an internal
facebook group about the benefits of yes
exclaims in fact so that everyone would
do and then just like wait for the
distal then and it would be time to
declare victory 20 clean so I thought we
thought this was wishful thinking
because Jeff's i'm only fuzzy that you
could might be bad after you've written
it when you tested it you happen to know
that it's actually not bad it's correct
no one almost no one reads with the
airport unless they're actually just
publish the stuff you have to know that
yourself in order to think that's a good
idea and you don't always know that your
side from your side I didn't want to
become that guy who who has to you know
where every child that was interface
with engineers they should we do
differently would have been on my
full-time job so as long as an old-style
doing something provides a code base
people are just going to continue
writing new code in that side like this
is the fundamental principle of how
could get certain large companies or
enlarged of the bases and you'll just
will never never went will never tip the
balance in favor can you start just not
okay so we have lots of steps with class
that extend copy properties you wanted
more of this class the riot extends
super business and the reason we wanted
one of that so that we could ship
something a little more sane and normal
so searching back and forth from the s5
yes yes I'd again but the net result is
a consistent way finding classes in
JavaScript so we've solved this problem
before actually it's just a source
transformation although this time it's
in the wrong direction is going from
current a JavaScript
future squirt yet until we write
transform to that in the other direction
but the good thing about the stand
transforms when you do it once once we
transfer no Lakotas desks and then
people to review it was also brining the
strips we're done and we have what looks
like six and it can be translated
documents that was certified can we
serve that face with my family it's all
so quickly because lots of slight
variations on the game that I showed
view of Kathie properties and class
sites and sometimes we'll just fine
graphic to prototype to find so the
script is going to be useful it needs to
sort of take care of a long tail of
different ways design classes we wanted
to generate pretty coat that sort of
looks as if it had been rewritten by
hand so that they actually looked with a
straight face ask other people to review
it and in consequence of that the
dishwasher pretty human readable awful
show an example and so proud of that
again was taking advantage of that idea
of non-destructive course
so as a personal active when I moved to
New York left sleeve is ranting I sort
of dragged my feet about finding your
team is what your prophecy people told
me there is crazy but what I found out
or the hypothesis that I cited the test
and see if I have hired or not was that
a large extent which you can provide a
justification for what you're doing and
get the cool to talk about it shortly
Facebook will let you work on whatever
you think as I you have to be
responsible for actually have an event
so that was a great luxury in doing this
project and it led to my working on the
JavaScript it just became so I work that
well so the script took about a week to
write initially then a while longer
today to hold it was responsible for
modernizing little north of 1,600 files
into this for about 350 thousand by
insertions deletions
which is a lot of food for human be
right in the face of a week or so but it
was trick to go in a much better place
so the script only actually can braid
1658 classes which is like more than
than ever thought of disorderly have one
class define but it checks the other day
to see how many classes there now are in
the new science of all these additional
classes will have been written by people
who looked at the classes of the count
of the code base and tried through the
same thing and there now I'm 3200 foots
so we've we've doubled the number of
glasses that had to be originally
converted and 1600 new classics like
core pieces of logic in facebook com
could this have been written by people
who probably agree wiki article probably
like didn't have to see that JavaScript
went when they just looked at code that
was lying around that happened to be
what they should be right and we're good
like that and everybody
do I have to lift a finger in process so
here's an example of a diff generated by
that skirts see this getting rid of the
importance of class and happy properties
those won't be needed anymore tap joking
becomes the name was a new class
actually we get rid of some stuff over
here let me pay I'd actually like to
point out is that if you're attempting
to do this kind of integration with a
tool that uses regular expressions which
is you know often out of it as a tool
you're going to miss things like this
it's very difficult to know just using
regular expression that because we
removed this print this is up here and
because it's open curly brace is
actually that now that would really
rates not even so she ated with this
object literal anyone knowing that you
need to not have closed and apprentices
skin which is very difficult to express
in terms of Wranglers
so much further now this is a small
example I picked it off of X the
consequences of changes file what
happened for hundreds more lines
actually having a tool that understands
the structure code and do this
aggression sound wait until being pretty
important okay so some of my lessons for
them from this experience first if you
go to a separate to make the output the
script between unreadable is amazing
people don't even question whether you
really sometimes would have had a
conversation with people about why
probably too much effort to change your
scripts and that's the first time we've
realized that you use this rate instead
of writing by hand totally reasonable to
just tweet something if you didn't if a
hand but you're using a script you want
scripts to working on cases I guess
that's more of a surprise that I'm a
beautiful lesson so if if you did say if
you start writing it's sort of
transformed scripts you should
definitely make sure you fill them with
bales out assertions but you're not
going to be able to handle everything
and it's going to really simplify your
life that you can just say you know what
at this point in code this has to be
true or i don't know what to do right
and i have a trick you might run it over
some files I just fail that's fine leave
the file a while
clear better job of that edge days it's
not important that script like this we
complete the sensitive handle everything
that's really important we sound and
since that thinks it's exceeded actually
did previous rep results you really have
to set yourself up to iterate rapidly to
such a long tail of Education and like a
large part of the project was just like
doing that mental fabulous of whether I
should fix its thing in 10 different
files or I should like teach the script
how to fix it and run it over this and
file food when you get down to the end
of the tail it's a maybe not that
important to teach the script everything
but more cookies really pays off to the
test scripts that ends up going how to
deal with lots of collision cases what's
what's really cool this gift the script
actually handles those things then you
can change your mind as often as you
like just blow away the changes and we
run the script and it's like you have
down at that way all along so if you do
have to fix rare cases by hand just
snapping them separate commits so you
can keep running the script on top of
that really pays off if you go the
effort to make advanced one can't run
scripts addenda gem in the sense that
keep running it on saying files to get
make some changes earlier you had
with one of the classes in the plan
doesn't know about you don't want to
like screw itself up encounter so that
previously that way so if you can write
it in such a way that like finds the old
stuff and recognizes it and leads it
untouched just kinda like gracefully
lose everything the direction of the way
you want things to be then will be much
better off if there's somebody grab you
here and New Age JavaScript and to learn
nothing else from the stock place is
really cool tunics tool called parallel
that lets you write scripts or just like
taking a single argument operate on one
file at a time and just like does all
the work for you write a lot of copies
of that script and in different
processes just really fully utilize in
here your hardware solely here two
hundred twenty seconds of sort of like
real subjective time only took 12
seconds to execute and I have everything
shopping twelve hundred percent cpu
utilization usually that's 100 if your
holdings in your
its gene you care about certainly not by
consulting what that's worth and so on
humans always at the right way in cases
like this which means if somebody's
actually working on some code you're
trying to improve face without how not
just finally rearrange the furniture you
should always let them at first and then
usually run the script right it's like
the best possible rebasing story because
you can just instantaneously remake all
the changes that could previously
haven't updated whatever you suck so
Leon how advantage I a mistake early on
in this project I guess you Chris I
thought I just now I'll activate this
yeah it's def and the people that I knew
what I said was working on just anthem
and they go in
kinds of classes and that feel pretty
hard when people this code it was
touching for for no discernible purpose
other than to change the language it was
written in get mad and rightfully so
because I haven't identified all the
stakeholders and I was trying to convert
whole swaths of code instead of burning
functional units at once especially
important lesson means that way as time
goes by all these tasks and yes point to
when you go to someone with a beautiful
they look work over here everybody loves
it you know there's notice and most part
or the estimates this is really generic
advice but yeah milestones are important
so Tomas plastics and this was my name
intermediate milestones it really
require turning everything into a new
style class but since I have that to
focus on if you get there unfortunately
so again fundamental law of large
releases this new code minutes existing
code and so to agree with the future is
longer going to pass how to do something
about that existing code if you want let
you settle in and things to have our
chances in them okay so
I work on a project called react that
actually uses the same technique to
create or advanced a new feature of
JavaScript that's not going to be part
of any teacher standing and we don't
even put that it will be so when I plan
but this too is possible you have a
bright idea that it's not slated for
universal adoption you can still modify
the programming which says you're using
and that and so if you do is you have to
be a pest that I'm talking about the
sort of like XML inside of JavaScript
syntax we have this too is why I would
go if you ever wanted to play with
right so what looks like HTML on the top
is turned into normal javascript
function pulse here and we do this
because well it will fly out earlier the
main reason actually is that there was
huge benefit from adding similar paths
to PHP internally and Facebook and
there's just a lot of value in having
seen style of doing things on the front
but also this syntax that we introduced
that doesn't exist million which
normally before it's a layer of
indirection so we get to be able to
change their mind about how that's
implemented which is something that you
always luxury in computer science
arguably doing something like this a
little bit equals 14 the language is
what less aggressive with something like
cocky stranger even most other
like restricting the language in use
Jess xls arbitrary JavaScript also fits
in angle brackets and final if yes I can
ever become started i'm saying that's
just not at all of our good technique
that we come up with not sure that it
needs to you know get widely adopted
dozen that's way too okay we could
though perhaps especially assets and
real demonstrate six so just briefly
there is a proposed new teacher
threatens critical to put strings so
this is what we have now Tippa let's
train will be a relatively small change
in front of the new further races where
interpolated values you'd want to put a
dollar sign whether baptist sits around
the whole multi-line string and you can
interpret the string with a custom
function by putting my desire for the
opening back deck so you can see the j
sx of the very day so that's one way to
do it and i would be more in line with
aggression yes except should head but I
guess I just ask you to think about
whether that's really worthwhile and if
you have the right hand but let me know
if this we could totally just search
stuff via not a sort of your precious or
extension
okay so it's in the summary of this
another thing that I've worked on in the
past six months or so and I'm job masada
here and worker that's helped me a lot
with this is Project Hope regenerator it
tastes actually very complicated new
teacher that's been proposed for
Standardization at Virgin JavaScript's
generator functions the yield keyword
which is a way of writing areas
basically functions offensive spend
themselves and then be risen Blair and
literally makes that available in
today's announcement so if you've used
generators in Python or C sharp my lord
happen then it's quite a lot like that
okay so I claim this is trickier here's
a whatever anybody puts Fibonacci
function up on a screen some real
contraction that they're about to go
through this is actually a good
demonstration of what's involved with
generators and making them available
today so this does not your function
just yeah because it's a limit and while
the a variable with less than or equal
to the limit it yields that a variable
and then updates a fee what used to be
and
it's easy to be the sound of a and B so
set sequence of images 0 1 1 2 3 5 8
reach number it's the son of the
previous notice the next number would be
13 if we have passed a one right so if
you take given achi of 10 and then
called next repeatedly the value that's
a catchable object that's returned from
that will be the value that was gilded
in each iteration of the loop none of
the very end we know that were done
because there's a done property which
kinds in a whole lot of it and that
becomes true so how far could we
translate this function in 21 no longer
contains that function star denotes a
generator or the yield keyword which is
not silent browsers so this I don't know
if you can see the date on the street
was made of 2013 let's hang go through
this in another one other secrets when i
bought a this is actually going pretty
well that i kept joking lee referring to
this side project as my wife's work for
so long I was terrified it might
actually be finished soon nowhere close
to being finished there were many
iterations left me like dead ends that
had to be circumvented so this was I was
wrong some of the trickiest a bit of a
written which may see more about me than
it up
but just objectively I wouldn't do it I
was totally doing now so what's involved
if we want to turn that Fibonacci
function into something that Archie
works and stay a chance okay well here's
the team function just with the curly
brace moved all the way down here that
need some space it's kinda get longer
unfortunately so the first thing we want
to do is take all of the variable
declarations and move them up to the top
of the function she's actually how
JavaScript behaves anyway it's called
variable voicing this is not changing
the semantics of anything so you can see
we have our day be annexed to the top
and everything else will of that is just
assignments those variables and so this
is absolutely change anything but what
it lets us do is wrap the rest of the
function in a generator function again
doesn't seem like a huge win but
suddenly the Fibonacci function itself
where water has to be a generate this
inner function expression can now
contain all the fields variable
assignments okay so now when you do
something about this function clean
although is now simpler problem the body
of the generator function needs to sort
of simulate the execution of the
function so that it can suspend and
resume so that's that switch statement
inside the loop and the case is an
associate or
jump charts so go to in a language that
I so too so in the first case which is
the one we fall into this context of X
is initialize to that 20 initially we
just do the first part of the function
but soft coral island so just what I say
and be limited and the second case that
we just fall into is where we test the
wildlife condition and just in case that
failed today is not less than or equal
to the limit this is how we jump around
we step contacts that next to some other
junk like a great I know this is Emily
breaks out of the switch statement loops
back around for another iteration of the
wildlife so if we did go there if we did
go there we'd be jumping down to this
case 11 at the very end of the function
where we gonna stop on a chain well if
the wire loop condition is not being
yeah then this is the this is the real
me the question they have been asking
yourselves what do we do about the Yale
instruction well for that we set context
up next the place where we want to
resume and we return it out and so what
we basically done is made it work to
return without i think is a return
keyword instead of you so this is the
sir turn a is what yield a used to be
okay so when we call next again context
up next will be six and we'll come right
back here place where we sat next to
Mandy and then we fall through to
setting 93 so we're coming back to the
head of the loop testing the wild
Bushman tulip tails so that's that's a
Rubicon sort of like dis rated string
through your new function body but at
this point we have no yields with no
function starts so we're in pretty good
shape this looks a lot like JavaScript
it today one more thing is that this
context has to come from somewhere ok so
we've wave my hands here and you'll
notice before return my conscience
question you pass it to this other
function will wrap generator that
returns a generator object has nice and
is responsible for creating the contents
and making sure it's past and everything
all right now it's kind of fiction that
is pretty hairy but compared to other
ways might imagine of implementing
generating functions such as you know
continuation passing style or trying
everything the promises what you end up
with is pretty simple efficient state
machine that you could arguably use
interruption without going to apologize
to anyone knowing you function calls and
although Finley sort of control
structures we have here it contain
yield statements if you have control
structure a while or additional doesn't
count fields in it just gets knitted as
it is there's literally no change in the
semantics tech code so those things
combined to make the generated code
actually II symbol is something you
could you can use so what else in that
context to I think I'm going to meet
this these parts of the slides there
someone self-explanatory to you if
you're actually interested in this it
turns out with a lot of features need
some support from the runtime you can
already tell but like something is going
on in the context that stuff method well
here it is we have to check and see if
there are any on handle exceptions so
you keep your own for the trim or so
that is just return the result so we
call context that stop with the very
bottom of the generator function that's
what it was doing proud of this example
for loose
so before in you need to keiths an
object and then move over them but we
want to sit kids that are no longer
actually in the object just in case you
deleted some keys while you're reading
of the outback so the context as this
keys method that turns a little area
that we can keep cooking for three new
values new keys and it'll be responsible
for deciding if if the key is anxious to
own the other and so that's just one
example cattle although the generated
code is this quite a bit longer than the
original code is a lot shorter than put
it then you have to repeat the logic
which handled by the keys method of
their intention it realized that's not
an explanation of what's going on over
the slides themselves in mauriceville
awesome painting on twitter or if you
have questions so there's this sort of
announcement page that about a generator
whirs open source facebook back to hepa
iowa / regenerated um has a sandbox if
you can play with it shows you the
results of however code pregnant life
house has a button to find but you used
it
properly the bike report form done a lot
of buzz reports that way I can go into a
lot more detail offline but obviously
describing facelets for generator
project and get that was the final ferry
and how everything trying to work in the
last few minutes of the stock though I
heard about something much less
technical and that is how you stay
motivated to work on the side project
that ends up being really difficult
especially when it's not directly
related to your day job and regenerated
was this for me I was working on it
buying myself for a long time not really
making any progress on it because I
would just forget where you know what
lanes ever stuck on the last time i did
have time to pay that back that just
wasn't enough context carry over from
the previous time to be a really
productive and liberating yeah but like
forgotten how I cited bench work with
the center so if you're gonna have a
heart side projects that takes a while
one thing that's absolutely important is
you have to make sure that saves fun so
a little bit counterintuitive is festive
language would you write tests then in
the long run as I thought it would be so
much more fun because we'll just have
this confidence that you have
everything whenever you touch the code
or find out did break it and you'll know
what you need to do immediately we cut
out for you this is also a little
counterintuitive like this is a side
project right you don't have to keep
working on what it's done so you have to
answer the question for yourself when
you're going to take breaks and what I
would argue is that you should take a
break you should like step away from
looking to it at those points where you
know what you're going to do next and
you also know that you're not going to
forget that because you written it down
and what that means is that even though
you could have stopped working usually
good on that thing that we knew it was
coming that the next time you sit down
to work inside projects the thing will
still be there we really jump right in
and do that and you'll have that one
mentioned at the beginning of the next
session rather than like never getting
around to it not entirely sure what you
were supposed to do so that's a really
good trick that you can employ yourself
yeah sometimes you want things to be a
secret but also get people in secret
don't be discouraged by similar projects
so maybe a little bit no actually the
size of me not to have mentioned that
google has protocol tracer which is an
effort to transpile a lot more features
of atmospherics and facebook is
attempting into that was 45 and it's a
pretty mature product and you definitely
use it and I could have been
mysteriously but the existence that's
something that that has limited support
for generates already by even though
they have head start I had the advantage
of knowing exactly where their support
accountant and and I knew that I could
do more things more correctly and it was
actually going to be a marginal benefit
to my attack on this problem after they
so in particular and regenerator you can
have a yield expression anywhere
literally anywhere expression here in
the language where it's increase your
generate support is limited to just
expression statements or the right-hand
side of assignment statements and if you
feel the skirt especially the taps but
some other project make you and go to
got something then you'd ever do then
realize other people will probably be
searched same reason and that's why
it's like if I fail I'm gonna say
perfect that means that gets you room to
work on something without worrying too
much to me other people or any kind do
at the same time so when should you ship
a side project click when is it that is
it ever done what are you going to get
out of shipping it that might get sooner
if you're willing to accept it you know
certain out blood reports so again these
our projects have to be mostly correct
when you ship them especially to 1.2
billion users that's just not the case
for side projects so my rule of thumb is
just ship as soon as you're confident
that you can fix you problems quickly as
they come in which is actually
overwhelmed with people sorry and both
liking your stuff and then finding lots
of problems in it you want to get
drownded so these people feel great
external contributors to report real
problems even kind of embarrassing
especially if they're straightforward to
fix that's just one of the Greek
experiences of open source social
interactions someone recording really
serious problem and you know you
together finding an elegant solution to
it everybody wins even the project
probably wasn't there some charity part
of us and you should definitely you know
instead of fixing everything just
randomly file no but don't worry about
fixing them before you ship so at least
when people find those funds
to the existing issue and say yeah large
not to get around that maybe you should
look at by the same token if you didn't
make it really easy for people to
contribute in small ways than they will
which is awesome so have a reporter
buckling in the live sandbox and like on
the order of like 20 or 30 will click
that like submitted codes which wasn't
working and I got to triage that family
found a lot of bucks and I know that
people spent like all the men fighting
those leg reports which is the location
where the value that Hansel project one
of the things that made me think it was
a good idea to build this in a world
where Google send our existed was that
in much the same way that's difficult to
upgrade your pipeline project to python
tree icon to using the google runtime is
sort of a large bell to swallow you get
lot of the things on with things you
didn't particularly one so this is one
feature for generators just generators
so you can restrict the scope of your
project that's other people interoperate
with it a lot more
and after you get it see different
people make meaningful contributions
because your project is quite so
monolithic get one is great because you
can do that Travis generation thing
where oh penne up pressure oh yeah I
beginning to work on regenerator happens
at about the same time I first played
with the generator sport nutrition and
talked myself into fine so yeah I son
book there was no place like terrifying
with the question again said when do you
make the decision whether to join the
project
I think i furnish that at the end well
there's almost like to this so the
pointer is just if all your tests to
pass on a trip a lot of tests then my
children virtue or requests to be able
to people get you know that good feeling
and then if you need to take it later
atomic exactly up to the standard style
with your gifts then you do that control
the product so a good cat fight against
cadets in this year and finally we this
is not always so easy but if you can get
non-technical friends excited about what
you're working on it's just you know if
they really excited excited for you
because you're excited because your
enthusiasm is infectious that counts for
a lot your technical friends to have
emotions and then you know they'll be
like yes I did both by the technical
side of things and I like the emotional
like story but here you're trying to
tell and you are yourself meeting the
best example of that you have the same
emotional needs
and you know you're the primary audience
to the story that you tell me what story
so the question was when you make the
decision to ship and you think you can
overlap still insisting things okay i
know i will admit that there was like
sunk cost fallacy going on like we're
kind of her life and but i couldn't
recommended it might be better and i
will say that like the reception I'm
happy news in the community that would
be of that people were able to see both
of their value of em just as one feature
grass materially and that it was that's
why we went for a treatment that one
particular feature so you know I I want
to hear about people's experiences using
a sure certainly if i come across people
reason it but i'm also excited to help
people like it generators are like the
main thing is there a safe in my surgeon
about strips so I'm like them get that
today instead of kind of 12 whole new
version one
if so slide that you had no arguments
yet you name that anything water doesn't
have to rest yep in Edinburgh yeah
you're a good question oh sure yeah the
question was just in the example where
we have that I've got breasts if you say
like that about birds and the answer is
yes it's just like any other members and
there's just mute so again about the
time but I think it does have to last
yeah the main thing the house there was
picking units of code to convert first
so first projects that Apple were live
relatively small internal projects that
weren't trying to effect immediately
that had tests just that that's that the
products are very small the facebook
importantly right nobody writes tasks
for internal products but we were a few
of them and let me like working scripts
and get accurate results and so I did
think it sort of persuade people to a
kind of review and accept those gifts
and wait and see if anything Lula and
those it'll move on from that degrading
larger internal projects like our tasks
to objectively important inside Facebook
would have been bad for it right but it
didn't because it was good state that
point and only then was really
reasonable to start talking about great
things like web messenger client which
is has tasks but a lot of people use
that
so we get to a point to a history of
successful convergence but once that was
in place
you know where our peoples are knew what
the technique involves your buzz
to the extent that's possible if you
want to convert yeah there are
specialists like comics premier there's
no safety in place right now keeps you
from like knowing what that's my ID
column club right now but you sort of
have to like write your code deliver
later it's also going to be part of
atmosphere sets for instance in the same
way that you can create a new function
objects using the capital F function
from structure there's going to be a
generator function constructed where you
have sex range with this value is yield
and I'm not going to work that although
technically because that would involve
bundling the whole compiler into the
runtime right now the runtime is like
1200 lines of code mfi and the whole
compiler the parser and we printer
many things like five kilobytes and that
tastes like a comp so that's a hand of
feature that's like they've heard the
respect that blossoms to be so great at
it yet so obviously you have a lot of
experience or my compiler design
especially compiler from InDesign like
Mexican parsing how did you first like
explore that
yeah the way that you said when it comes
to English grips because there's this
huge springboard get started with which
is the Escrima JavaScript parser and so
it no it's good multitude eyes and I'm
saying person I asked you for you as
you're comfortable working with
basically JSON at that point pick up
feel crazy so the early stages of person
are irregular speculate re ahead roots
or a hero of mine these presents so yeah
check it up and in general electric for
Jewel's earliest didn't have to rate
yeah or bison style language
it's the part that was interesting was
the transformation less so this rescue
okay other questions on a parent and
thanks a lot for Joe